the Rio Grande River marks the border
and in recent weeks barriers have been
erected in the water objects at critics
allege pose a fatal threat to those
attempting to swim across the governor
of Texas says the measures have been
implemented because of what he describes
as the lacks border policies of the
Biden Administration Texas has had to
take unprecedented steps in responding
to the crisis caused by the bad
Administration On the Border Abbott's
measures are now coming under Fire from
prominent politicians and human rights
groups after emails by a State Trooper
revealed a number of alleged abuses in
recent weeks on one occasion the trooper
says they were ordered to push children
back into the Rio Grande river and not
to provide Asylum Seekers with water
with temperatures at well over 37
degrees Celsius
in another incident a pregnant woman got
caught up in the wire resulting in a
miscarriage
in his email the trooper expressed his
belief in Abbott's mission to establish
border security but he had this to say
about their actions
I believe we have stepped over a line
into the inhumane we need to operate it
correctly in the eyes of God
some members of Congress from Texas were
quick to condemn the governor's policy
no matter where you stand on the issue
of immigration or border security
there's a difference between wanting
border security and carrying out
policies that could lead to people's
drowning deaths the White House also
responded with a withering attack on the
Republican Governor describing the
measures as Despicable and dangerous and
the indecency the human indecency that
we're seeing potentially if this is true
is just wrong it is just completely
completely wrong and but I would say
sadly it would not be surprising from a
governor who let's not forget on
Christmas Eve put migrant children on
the streets in below zero degree
temperature that's what we saw from this
Governor the Texas Department of Public
Safety has denied the allegations now
the claims are being investigated by the
inspector General's office Mike Hannah
Al Jazeera Washington